Angela Merkel has come to offer help she
visited passo on Tuesday the German
Chancellor was getting an overview of
the situation in the flood-stricken part
of the country she wants to show people
the government cares as does Bavarian
state premier Horst as a whole [ __ ] the
mayor the local representative to the
federal parliament and the heads of the
aid and rescue organizations are also
with the group sometimes it seems a bit
crowded but all eyes are on the
Chancellor trying to see how she'll
handle a natural disaster they didn't
wait long for a response the state will
do something the federal government has
allocated 100 million euros for flood
relief we'll do it on a 50/50 basis of
course we're going to help the other
states saxony entering in and
saxony-anhalt and if the funds run out
then we'll talk again Aden money is
what's going to help people here the
most but this is also about politicians
using the media to shape their image to
show they aren't afraid of getting their
hands dirty media consultant Klaus Cox
advises public figures not to be shy
yes skipped Anna gooses leadership it's
a real object lesson in in Flute the one
who goes to the site of the flooding and
shows empathy with the victims is
usually rewarded with major political
success org Lord hurt
especially if it's a flood like this one
which has devastated southern and
eastern Germany and pasal the water is
13 meters deep the last time the Danube
was this high was five hundred years ago
the military rescue and civil defense
workers and firefighters are all working
to hold back the tide others would join
in but they've got to get themselves
sorted first lava Bush is one she's a
student and lived here with her
boyfriend until the flood that is get
that out under stove get everything out
even with water levels dropping and the
help of many friends the job is still a
mammoth one water and mud have damaged
everything Laura Bush says the visiting
politicians can't actually do much to
help and there's a campaign element to
it as well but Merkel's visit still
makes the victims feel better
it's encouraging because the situation
in Purcell is really bad but now that
mrs. Merkel is here we can hopefully
count on government support still you
can't rely on anything and 100 percent
they say donations are coming in but how
do we apply for them everything is still
a bit uncertain Laura Bush has been
through this before when her home in
Grima Saxony was flooded in 2002 that
event was dubbed the flood of the
century until now back then social
democratic el-hajj Trudeau was
Chancellor he donned boots and looked
grave as he inspected stricken areas
scoring a political bullseye by playing
the part of a doer crisis manager and a
shoulder to cry on all the more so
because his Christian Democrat rival
Edmund Stoick was nowhere to be seen
Cox says in retrospect that the
appearance clinched reelection for
Schroeder
intuitively exploited the political
opportunities of this situation we know
that stiver was vacationing and had no
desire to interrupt his holiday that was
a huge political miscalculation Loida
came across as a great populist because
tofo wasn't inaud when the water is
bubbling out of pumps and residents are
hoping for help and support it's a real
chance to make political capital
especially for the incumbent
naturally that leaves pair Stein book at
a disadvantage the social democrat
opposition candidates is again having
difficulty appearing truly sympathetic
idea mentees lamins on FM as someone who
lived with his family in a house close
to the Rhine I have a concrete idea of
what it means when floodwaters inundate
a house that's why I believe that I can
sympathize with those who are struggling
with the adversities generated by this
disaster these in village cut midi
cicadas wolf it took him from home
whether it's in pass our other affected
areas merkel is showing compassion but
stopping short of pity such appearances
are like walking a tightrope
it's tricky if it's overdone people say
we're being taken for a ride too little
and it goes unnoticed you need to find
the right balance so we Rhoda was very
good at it Merkel makes a good attempt
it's not perfect but it's much better
than the rest right Besser iced teas
accordion figure 1
after an hour the Chancellor moves on to
the next stricken region with four
months left until the general election
it's likely that our visits to flooded
parts of the country have garnered some
popularity points
you